Zur Sendung "Mona mittendrin:
Im Brocki der zweiten Chance"
erhielten wir extrem viele Reaktionen
von euch.
Vielen Dank. Es gibt auch noch
einige offene Fragen.
Darum ist Sandra hier.
Hast du die Kommentare
eigentlich gelesen?
Warst du auf Social Media?
Ich habe das mit Absicht
nicht getan,
weil man ja nicht weiss,
welche Reaktionen kommen.
Hattest du Angst?
- Ja. - Wovor?
Dass es böse Zungen gibt.
Darum liess ich das bleiben.
Willst du die Kommentare
über dich hören?
Ja, gerne.
- Also:
Danke.
Jö, danke.
Beim Thema Sozialhilfe
rechnet man immer auch damit,
dass es Menschen gibt, die finden:
"Schmarotzer, alle zu faul."
Aber das Gegenteil war der Fall.
Das hat mich riesig gefreut.
Es gab viele, die wie Regula sagten:
"Ich finde es gut, dass diese
Menschen eine Stimme bekommen."
Oder Thomas schreibt:
So waren die meisten Reaktionen.
Es gibt einige offene Fragen,
die ich mit dir anschauen möchte.
Da wollen einige
etwas von dir wissen.
Zum Beispiel:
Ich glaube,
ich war einfach sehr arrogant.
Ich habe gut verdient.
Ja, ich hatte ein Auto.
Ja, wirklich ...
Mehr rechts als links,
ich weiss es nicht.
Ich fand einfach,
die sind zu faul zum Arbeiten.
Ohne darüber nachzudenken,
dass es auch Menschen sind.
Und dass sie eine Geschichte haben.
Eine nächste Frage:
Mir blieb nichts anderes übrig.
Ich musste es tun,
ich hatte kein Geld mehr.
Und zu diesem Zeitpunkt
konnte ich nicht arbeiten.
Weil ich notfallmässig
operiert werden musste.
Der Gang zum Sozialamt.
Einige von euch schilderten,
wie das für euch war.
Jemand sagt:
Gabriela schreibt:
Das fand ich schockierend.
- Ja, sehr.
Man geht ja nur,
wenn man keinen Ausweg mehr sieht.
Und dann wird man verdächtigt.
Ging dir das auch so?
Ich höre viele schlimme Dinge.
Das ist zwar etwas vom Schlimmsten.
Aber ich habe positive Erfahrungen
gemacht.
Auch bei der Anmeldung.
Ich hatte einfach Mühe
mit dem Papierkrieg.
Was man alles haben muss - da war ich
zu Beginn völlig überfordert.
Ich verlor fast die Nerven.
Wer half dir?
- Niemand.
Ab und zu fragte ich meine Mutter.
Ich wurstelte das einfach durch.
Jetzt mache ich das mit links -
man muss reinkommen.
Am Anfang ist es schon ...
Den Papierkrieg fand ich erdrückend.
Aber bei den Menschen -
vielleicht hatte ich einfach Glück -
habe ich nur positive Erfahrungen
gemacht.
Jemand fragt:
Ich kann es mir immer leisten,
wenn sie etwas will.
Sie bekommt ja nicht jede Woche
etwas. Taschengeld bekommt sie auch.
Gewisse Dinge kann sie nicht
ersparen, die bekommt sie dann.
Aber wie machst du das,
wenn du zu wenig Geld hast?
Dann spare ich das anderswo ein.
Und ich spare auch.
Ich lege immer 100 Fr. zur Seite. Ich
will auch wieder mal in die Ferien.
Weisst du ...
Das reicht wirklich?
- Es muss.
Sonst können wir nicht in die Ferien.
Unter den Menschen, die v.a.
von der Sozialhilfe betroffen sind,
gibt es viele Alleinerziehende,
das hätte ich nie gedacht.
Jede fünfte Ein-Eltern-Familie
in der Schweiz bezieht Sozialhilfe.
Wie du auch,
viele alleinerziehende Mütter.
Viele haben uns geschrieben:
Jemand anders fragt,
ob es dein Ziel ist,
irgendwann wieder selbstständig
und unabhängig
von der Sozialhilfe zu sein?
Absolut,
das ist mein grösster Wunsch.
Wie realistisch ist es,
dass du das schaffst?
Es kommt darauf an,
was mein Fuss machen will.
Wenn man das wüsste.
Ob er Ruhe gibt
oder ob es weitergeht.
Eine neue Stelle zu finden
und wieder zu verlieren -
ich hoffe nicht,
dass sich das wiederholt.
Es ist klar: Wenn ich eine Stelle
angeboten bekommen würde,
würde ich mich riesig freuen,
hätte aber auch panische Angst.
Es gab einen Satz in der Sendung,
der viele beschäftigt hat.
Ein Satz von Adi.
Als wir die Wohnung räumten
und darüber nachdachten,
warum immer mehr Menschen
in der Schweiz keinen Platz finden
im ersten Arbeitsmarkt.
Und er sagte:
"Die Schweiz hat das Herz verloren."
Das beschäftigte viele Menschen.
Viele Menschen haben sich während
der Sendung generell gefragt:
"In was für einem Land
leben wir eigentlich?"
In was für einer Gesellschaft
leben wir? Was ist der Wert?
Jemand schrieb, es sei ein
Armutszeugnis für die Schweiz,
so ein reiches Land und doch
fallen viele durch die Maschen.
Jolanda schrieb:
Hast du auch dieses Gefühl?
- Ja.
Das ist Tatsache.
Etwas Kleines reicht -
und man ist weg vom Fenster.
Und es wird nicht besser,
sondern schlimmer.
Adi hat es auf den Punkt gebracht.
Das hat mich beim Lesen
am meisten beschäftigt.
Jene, die ihre persönlichen
Erfahrungen schilderten.
Wenn sie beschreiben, wie es ist,
plötzlich kein Mensch mehr zu sein,
man wird plötzlich zu einem Fall,
zu einem Bittsteller.
Und auch dieser Papierkrieg,
irgendwo zwischen
Arbeitslosenversicherung,
zwischen RAV, IV,
Ärzten und Sozialamt.
Das empfinden extrem viele
als sehr zermürbend.
Wie Pascal schreibt:
"Es kann jeden erwischen."
Oder Michael sagt:
Wenn man diese einzelnen Beispiele
liest, merkt man:
Manchmal hat man ein wenig Pech
und plötzlich steht man
am Rande der Gesellschaft.
Und junge Menschen. Jemand schilderte
ein persönliches Beispiel.
21 Jahre,
nach der Lehre nichts gefunden:
Kannst du dir vorstellen, was
passiert, wenn man nach der Lehre ...
Ja, ich bin etwas geschockt.
Also, irgendwie ...
Ja, es geht wirklich nicht mehr auf.
Was muss sich in der Gesellschaft
ändern?
Da gab es auch Vorschläge.
Z.B. das bedingungslose
Grundeinkommen.
Daniel und andere
führten das ins Feld:
Wie ihr wisst, stimmten wir 2016 über
das bedingungslose Grundeinkommen ab,
ein grosser Teil der Schweizer/-innen
war dagegen.
Aber wer weiss,
vielleicht kommt das Thema ja
irgendwann wieder
auf das politische Parkett.
Brigitte schrieb:
Es gibt ganz viele Sozialhilfe-
bezüger/-innen, die arbeiten wollen.
Das fiel mir extrem auf:
Wenn man immer die Vorstellung hat:
Es ist bequem,
man liegt im gemachten Nest
und bekommt Geld vom Staat.
Das sah ich bei euch, ihr sagt: "Fast
gleich schlimm wie zu wenig Geld
ist es, keine Aufgabe zu haben,
nicht arbeiten zu können."
Das hast du auch so erlebt?
- Absolut.
Etwas fürs Geld tun.
Wir haben eine Sozialhilfe, können
etwas tun, wir bekommen ja Geld.
Und wir bekommen auch einen Lohn.
Klar ist das nicht viel.
Aber Gerry hat das super gesagt:
Wir machen etwas fürs Geld.
Wir nehmen das nicht einfach so.
Vielen Dank, Sandra, dass du so offen
über das Leben mit Sozialhilfe warst.
Alles Gute und toi, toi, toi,
dass du einen Job findest.
Danke.
Ich möchte mit einem schönen Wunsch
von Yoli aufhören,
der mir gut gefiel:
Danke euch fürs Vertrauen,
für eure persönlichen Geschichten
und die vielen Feedbacks.
Wenn ihr andere Themenanregungen
habt, die wir aufnehmen sollen,
schreibt es in die Kommentarspalte
oder schickt uns eine Mail:
monamittendrin@srf.ch.
Ich bin gespannt und freue mich,
danke.